hi I am Steven from the team at simon
Sinek our team has been remote for as
long as we've existed which has been
over 10 years now and more and more
individuals and teams and even
organizations now are operating in a
remote fashion many of us are being
forced to and many of us are choosing to
because working as a remote team offers
some great flexibilities and
opportunities we have a ritual on our
team called huddle because working
remote can be challenging it's hard to
stay on the same page it's hard to stay
connected it's hard to build trust when
we don't have that water-cooler we don't
have a shared office space and so one of
the ways that we keep our team connected
and tight is we host a call a weekly
call called huddle we do our huddle on
Monday mornings it's an opportunity for
us all to get on we use a video
conferencing call a zoom call everyone
has their video on we ground together we
connect together and the call is built
and devoted completely to building
relationship with one another when a lot
of teams huddle I think they talk about
business but this team huddle is about
each other we get on the same page we
share what's on our heart and minds we
share what's great you share what sucks
we give each other high-fives and we
answer a question of the week and we
share a story of why we do what we do
it's 75 minutes every week simply
devoted to building relationship with
each other because relationship truly is
the foundation of what we can accomplish
as a team and so in these times when
more and more people are working remote
we thought we would give you a taste of
what our huddle looks like we as a team
came together for a short abridged
version of our huddle instead of 75
minutes we gave you a taste of what it
actually looks like and we did it in
about 15 minutes
so we hope by you watching this huddle
you get a sense of how we connect and
perhaps yeah you can adopt this in your
own unique way for your team
it helps and here's our hub good morning
everyone it is Wednesday March 18th it's
lovely to be with you all and I'm going
to pass it to mr. shedletsky who will do
our grounding exercise so we can all
become present and be with each other
awesome guys a um just invite everyone
to take a deep breath cuz these times
are normal times and let's get back to
us so if you're sitting put your feet on
the floor feel your feet on the floor in
through your nose and out through your
mouth
two more in through your nose
just fill your body
and feel your presence here for each
other
okay
a reminder to everyone just turn off
your notifications and we're here for
each other Sharon back over to you
excellent thank you who has some love to
share let's high-five each other for the
awesome things we've been doing for each
other this week Simon please kick it off
I have a high-five for Melissa um we've
been working together on redoing our
what used to be called PGR
we have now renamed it it's gonna be
called GNP which is growth and
performance it's how we review each
other and it's just been a pleasure
working with Melissa we've completely
reinvented something new so it's
completely our own we know we have a 16
page review process it's down to two
pages it's super super super easy and
simple and just big high five - Lissa
for doing all the research and just it's
been an absolute joy working with her
and I think what we have is really
really good so thanks Melissa
I've also a couple high-fives actually
first one to Steven shedletsky or just
staying on the grind in community man we
do uh way to hop in stay on top of
things one also for a Siobhan for just
stand on top of messaging and setting up
meetings and everything like that when
it comes to product development and Lee
also for just keep them out light and
always be in the spark and smile when we
need it so high fives around I have a
couple um first to the ignite leadership
team and really everybody um since my
life got a little turned around and
upside down on Monday so thank you all
so much for holding the space for me so
I could sort of drive through the night
to be with my family and for my health
and my own mental health so just I can't
thank you enough for just letting me
sort of pack up the car and drive and
get where I needed to be at a moment's
notice it's thank you from the bottom of
my heart
I've got one for Siobhan who is doing
such a masterful job coordinating all of
these big projects and a lot of details
a lot of internal and external
communication Siobhan you are the rock
that is keeping a lot of these big
projects moving forward and just a big
high-five because I know you're juggling
kids at home at the same time so way to
go girl
awesome I know you may have more high
five so as you know
high fives can happen when Christina
at anytime at any time I love that time
at any time um so we're gonna do our
check-ins and our question of the week
this week is I think a pretty topical
one we're a remote team we've been doing
this jam for many years and as we know
there are lots of individuals and teams
that for the first time ever are forced
to embrace virtual teaming and remote
teaming and so our question the week
this week is what tip or advice would
you give to someone anywhere in the
world who for the first time now is on a
remote team who would like to kick off
and do check-ins first and sharing RMS I
will also be your timer so um we keeping
I'll be giving you a 30-second warning
because we need to get two minutes for
our chickens so if you see anything like
this that means you've got 30 seconds to
wrap up your thoughts awesome who wants
to kick off our chicken
you
I mean do it so question of the week I
think I spent about 11 hours on virtual
meetings yesterday and more to come
today so my biggest thing is I like to
be super present I do turn off all
notifications like we already talked
about I go to ear phones instead of just
the speakers so that I can protect
confidentiality and I and I always make
sure that I'm there early I've got
everything I need before I actually get
going so I got my glass of water I've
got everything that I could possibly be
right there so that's my that's my tip
for the week there I've got a pretty big
thing here so in addition to my roles
with ignite leadership my wife and I
also have Cherry Creek dance in Denver
of course and we had to make a really
tough call to shut down all in studio
classes and and that looked very
different on Friday afternoon than it
did when we actually told the team on
Sunday so it's it's been an incredible
emotional just weekend and as we shift
into a new phase of life here of going
all virtual classes all online and that
sort of thing so which actually leads me
to a high five which is to shed when I
needed to write this letter to just kind
of express to us and we ended up filming
it and I sent an email and text a shed
and I just said hey I need a little help
with this could you mind reading this
and she had just dropped everything in
order to to be there for me which I
major kudos my friend that was that was
an amazing move and it it really helped
me bring up the bring up why we do what
we do in this so thank you so much for
that but that's the biggest thing that's
on my heart mine today
Thanks thanks to the team for being here
too
awesome lead pass it on to your next
culprit here I'm going to go with how
about David okay can you hear me
great yeah I too likely trying to keep
everything super organized to be
prepared in advance of any calls for
conversations so that I can be abuse I
would say what's on my heart and mind
right now is staying healthy that's a
huge passion of mine and I think given
what's happening in the world right now
is super important for everybody so when
I think about the things that we can do
to control our health those things would
be our nutrition and our movement as
well as our sleep but for nutrition what
comes to mind are that there are some
very simple things that we can do avoid
sugar being number one refined sugar
especially sugar is pro-inflammatory
it's processed by the liver in a very
particular way and that puts out a lot
of things into your system that are not
good that actually work against immunity
as far as immunity is concerned you want
to consume foods that are high in
vitamin E zinc
David we just lost to you when I mute
there
we lost you add zinc I think a my back
got my computing very strange omega-3
fatty acids basically fish nuts
basically the Mediterranean diet would
be the best I know I know that's not the
easiest thing for everybody to get to
but super important as far as movement
is concerned super important that you
move in three planes of motion for those
of you who don't know what that is it's
the sagittal the frontal plane and the
rotational plane so when you think of
movement most exercise is done up and
down or in this plane movement in the
frontal plane is side-to-side and
rotational movement is this way
everybody focuses on the muscular system
super-important but the skeletal system
is the thing that's gonna take the
biggest hit from sitting which is what
everybody's gonna be doing for a long
time so if you have a limited space make
sure you're moving in those three planes
okay I'm gonna pass this now on to Leila
I am in Colorado I got here last night
around midnight and as much as I really
really really didn't want to travel
right now umm I felt like it was the
best thing to do to just come and be
with my family and help and support
especially my grandma being near my mom
I think I told you guys before she
wasn't feeling well earlier this week we
were worried she has just an ear
infection upper respiratory infection
she's on antibiotics and feeling better
so that's good news um but I'm glad to
be here um definitely it you know as
wonderful as it sounds to be locked in
my apartment alone for two weeks it's
it's nice to be around family um right
now my mom has brought me breakfast in
bed would recommend
um question of the week I would
recommend so I have two things one which
Stephen said at the beginning of the
call turning your phone your computer if
you have a Mac I don't know about other
computers but they do not disturb
function saves my life all the time so
that when Ron calls when I'm trying to
focus on like an email block or
something I don't have things just
popping up on my screen or my phone
lighting up and the other thing is
having a clean designated works
workspace so like my apartment in New
York I don't have an office but I make
sure that if there's any clutter around
that would be bothering me that would be
a distraction I make sure to sort that
out at the beginning of the day and then
designate a designated workspace my
kitchen counter well working in bed or
on the couch think Sharon is you know
comfy it's not really the best working
environment um Sharon back to you thank
you for sharing everyone who has a story
of why we do what we do
how do you hey Jesse hi um my furry
buddy what you do is related to my
mother um she's been she's had cancer
and she had her three-month checkup and
during the checkup they found some more
things and so they want to do a biopsy
and during the biopsy procedure she
started bleeding and after after the
procedure and so the when they were
trying to send her home they're just
supposed to be an outpatient thing the
nurse was like oh I don't think she
should go home and the doctor was like
yeah we're just gonna send her home but
she kept leaving it bleeding and
bleeding and so they ended up keeping
her and it finally dawned on me why that
nurse felt safe enough to kind of
question the doctor and say let's keep
her because she's continuing to bleed
and it was because um one of my dance
mom friends she works at the hospital
and my mom was act and she had told me
once I haven't told her what I do and
who I work for for signing and she's
like oh well in are like orientations
and trainings we always watch the Golden
Circle we always are learning about
Simon and his things so it dawned on me
that's why that nurse felt safe enough
to question that doctor because that's
the kind of training that they get at
that hospitals so I mean that could have
been a matter of life and death
gratefully thankfully it wasn't but I'm
grateful to that nurse and I'm grateful
to that hospital that they embrace these
principles and practices so thank you
thank you so much Jesse um guys I know
we're a remote team and some of this is
normal for us and yet some things are
very different and more families around
and were more isolated just remind us to
connect with each other that we have
each other's back
suffering is done alone that struggling
is done together
let us struggle together and we'll move
forward together love you all
[Music]